welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up a confluent cloud cluster via
the google cloud marketplace confluent
is pioneering a fundamentally new
category of data infrastructure focused
on data in motion
its cloud native offering is the
foundational platform for data in motion
which is designed to be the intelligent
connective tissue to enable real-time
data from multiple sources allowing it
to constantly stream across the
organization
and in fact confluent founders are the
original creators of apache kafka and
are helping organizations set their data
in motion even faster with their fully
managed service for apache kafka
now let's explore how to set up a
confluent cloud cluster
let's start by searching for confluent
cloud in the google cloud marketplace
for this demo we'll choose the solution
apache kafka on confluent cloud
the landing page will display
information about the solution
details about pricing and support
the pricing information displays a high
level estimate of charges pricing for
the solution is based on your
subscription plan
let's click the subscribe button to
launch the solution
[Music]
start first by choosing a billing
account and agreeing to the terms below
which are the terms about subscription
fee build monthly and cancelling the
service
you'll also notice the pricing
calculator which can help you see
estimated costs based on factors like
time frame and subscription plan
[Music]
once your purchase has been accepted you
will see another page which requires you
to register with confluent cloud
you'll be able to manage apache kafka on
confluent cloud
make sure to sign in or log in with your
confluent account
on confluent cloud we will set up a
cluster
for the purpose of this demo i will
create a basic cluster
choose a region
we'll choose us4 las vegas
choose an availability we'll choose
single zone
[Music]
now we'll launch our cluster
next let's test our cluster using
confluent cli on the google cloud shell
there you have it apache kafka on
confluent cloud with a click of a button
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy the solution on
your own
thanks for watching
[Music]
you